Bipin's bringing on what
is a model of a really amazing
application of atomic time.
This is a model of the
global positioning system.
It consists of 24 satellites
constantly orbiting the earth,
such that wherever
you are on the earth,
you have four
satellites above you.
Now, each of these satellites
contains an atomic clock.
And they're all synchronised.
So if you were to measure
the time signals given out
by the four satellites
that are nearest you
and compare the time
taken for that signal
to reach you from
these four satellites,
very much like in the story
of navigation of Harrison,
you could use time to
actually measure and determine
your position on the Earth.
And that's exactly what one
of these receivers does.
It picks up the signal from
these atomic clocks orbiting
the earth in the satellites.
Now Elliah
is up on the roof.
Can you hear me, Elliah
I can, Neil.
Great.
What have you got?
Well, I've got a GPS
receiver here in my hands.
And you can see on the
display it's telling me
my position at the moment.
Is 51 degrees 30.571
minutes north of the equator
and 8 degrees 0.564
west of Greenwich.
Can you show us how
many satellites?
Yes, I've got other
screens on here, which
also show us where we are.
You see it's got a map
of the world built-in.
So it's telling us we're
somewhere near Westminster.
And this screen tells
us we're picking up
signals from six satellites.
Now, Elliah, can
you move across the roof?
So we can actually
see the change.
And this change is
going to be very small.
But the change in the
readings on the receiver.
Let's try that.
Yes, Neil.
I think you can
see quite clearly
that the upper display is now
saying 0.579 degrees north.
Before it was 0.570.
So only that tiny movement
across the roof this
has picked up.
Well, that's wonderful.
Thank you very much,
Elliah. In fact,
this positioning, this ability
to detect position on the Earth
has an enormous number
of applications.
You may have seen some of
the applications discussed
for motorists.
But also applications
for sight-disabled people
and even probably for some
more surprising customers.
Sheep are big purchasers
of GPS systems.
In fact, not the sheep
themselves, of course,
but the farmer has
to look after them.
Because imagine.
We're up in the hills.
It's raining.
Got lots of sheep.
They're all over the place.
You don't really want to be
out looking where they are.
And your dog refuses to go.
So just strap one of
these receivers to one
of the backs of the sheep.
Sit at home.
A cup of tea.
And you monitor the
position of the sheep.